c'est ça leur va faire l'interview in
love alors ça va les amoureux ça va ça
va toujours ensemble à ce que je vois en
est fidèle vous vous êtes rencontrés la
première fois dans une boîte de nuit qui
a abordé l'autre en premier chez lui
c'est moi ouais ouais c'est lui je me
souviendrai toujours de cette vanne de
merde que tu m'as fait j'avais un tester
c'était l'époque où les téléphones
portables commencer je suis prêtre en
jaune une caisse était à peu près une
valise si je l'avais accroché à ma
ceinture
tu vois tu vois moi que ce soit aux
bidons d'essence attend maintenant je
vais passer dès 4 heures du matin tu
m'as dis donc tu attends vraiment un
coup de filet 4 heures en boîte il est
parti du maire con et je me suis dit
waouh temps que je passe un coup de fil
à l'eau vous n'avez pas de répartie donc
est ce qu a eu beaucoup de disputes
depuis que vous êtes ensemble ouais
surtout les jours quasiment tous les
joueurs à propos de quoi la dernière
passe et toujours c'est super légers
comme sujet situent sur des conneries
sur sa coupe d'ailleurs ramzi est ce qui
vous arrive de surprendre
eric en train de regarder d'autres
filles que hbo ouais et alors j'ai envie
de me livrer là je dis la vérité avant
que la merde dans un endroit aussi oui
c'est bien ici quand même vous êtes un
couple libéré tous les deux vous
autorisez l'éminent patronat
je ne connais même pas trop quand y'a un
mec d'extérieur qui arrivent comme on a
vraiment être marrant pied j'entends
bien avec l'un des deux je le voyais
piquionne avec le temps ça m'énerve à
vos parents l'ont bien pris quand vous
avez ramené un arabe à la maison très
très bien away est pourtant resté super
catholique c'est à dire avec une cape
est toutefois vraiment super on va les
organismes et mais c'est trop phase est
très très catho les égorger des poulets
des grands besoins la vérité est vrai
que c'était vraiment râlant prix comment
quand vous êtes arrivé avec lui il l'a
pas encore dit il encore on attend de
l'annoncé eric est ce que ramzi a déjà
menacé de vous quitter
non sans jeune homme championnat semble
que non mais vous amuser non je me six 6
mois j'ai menacé mois si vous aimez ça
je le dis pas parce que là c'est trop et
trop mal
wanted est venu d'ailleurs lorsque vous
avez connu il a il avait plus de cheveux
non c'était ridicule
il avait un petit peu de jeu et poussent
tu vois comme iliad par exemple vraie
porsche cabriolet qui comme ça l'a
vraiment tu vois leurs élèves de sainte
anne
non mais tout ce qu'il a perdu là il
arrêtera à agen même si personne
n'arrive à accrocher sur l'écran est ce
qu'au bout de dix ans la présence de
l'autre peut devenir pénible ah oui là
enfin parce que c'est trop lassés sortie
trop en faire ah oui j'en peux plus
maintenant c'est le fait de passer 300
jours par an avec lycée ça devient
pénible par la force des choses mais
notre amitié n'est pas pénible mois
trois jours sur lui il me manque
il ya une lassitude qui se fait jour
quand même comment pardon il ya une
lassitude qui se fait connaître des mots
qui sont dans le queens ouais situe
juste après l'assaut les sols la
scission l'asie non mais quand tu disais
tout à l'heure si on se surprenait on
arrive encore à surprendre
ouais on l'a bien des trucs vous faites
plus comme il ya dix ans quoi bah là il
arrive peu abordé comme un vrai souci il
me regarde maintenant avec les autres
alors ramzi était provisoire et de shana
qui prend l'avion est ce que l'autre
l'accompagnent toujours l'aéroport
voilà rami disent bon voyage et connais
je les connais pas mal quand même et
c'est vrai qu'à l'extérieur ils sont pas
un
on pourrait penser que ils vont faire la
ribouldingue ensemble et tout mais pas
du tout les mêmes occupations savez je
n'ai rien à voir et de cesser pour
celle-ci peut-être quelques couples
tiens c'est que beaucoup de plaisir à se
retrouver parce que c'est ce à quoi les
mêmes ce que des gens normaux dehors
c'est à dire bonjour monsieur quand
allez-vous ça et des joueurs nba
ça ne peut pas c'est un fossé à chaque
on a souvent cette réflexion des gens
qui lui disent oui je t'aime bien toi
tout seul et que vous êtes tous les deux
mais c'est un contrôle là dessus je me
vois ouais j'ai plus rien de la physique
qui se vit et moi j'ai un jerrican est
ce qu'il vous reste encore des choses à
découvrir chez l'autre ah je pense
formation dominante on se regarde on se
regarde on bosse pas met en avant vous
pensé rester ensemble pour toute la vie
on accepte cette petite ambition là et
puis toute façon personne ne veut de
nous
gg je pensais faire un show chacun sait
jamais trop notre prochain spectacle on
voudrait faire et c'est avec ça que solo
mais sur la même chaîne
en même temps on faire à la con comme
vous êtes toujours aussi heureux d'être
ensemble
oui monsieur avait bien dit maintenant
ah ouais c'est bien elle est bien on a
vécu tout ça ensemble on fait les cons
et on a des vestes et des chenilles j'ai
couru aujourd'hui la marque de
saint-philippe et c'est carrément une
celio alors